j'aime bien ta lyx a des idées à
partager des idées pour changer le monde
bon par contre je suis un peu un cynique
de tedx le sujet qui que qui me touche
vraiment c'est le passage à l'action
j'aime bien cette bd disques a cédé
l'alizé pas je vous la raconte ça on a
tous sont pas tous est potes qui nous a
dit un jour à mes facebook mais j'avais
trop eu l'idée avant tout le monde mais
normand c'est moi qui devrait être riche
eon qui a cédé imagine un formulaire en
ligne on viendra expliquer ça j'étais à
une soirée il ya trois potes qui m'ont
entendu je peux le prouver
et puis on dit ah ouais je devrais avoir
5 % de la boîte et puis on vous enverra
les et une par la poste évidemment
évidemment ça se passe pas comme ça la
partie dure c'est pas tellement avoir
l'idée la partie dure c'est la
réalisation c'est la rencontre entre
l'idée et la réalité et essai et c'est
un peu ce que l'expliquent à obélix nous
raconter aujourd'hui isabelle qui est
venu nous parler de 2 comment un petit à
petit elle est passée à l'action pour
habiter son balai dont 2,6 traoré sur la
manière dont dont elle a pris ses pieds
elle a pris un avion et elle est allée
confrontés ceux qui avaient massacré une
partie de la salle de sa famille ah oui
un tout petit truc aussi c'est un autre
passage à l'action beaucoup plus petit
elle était venue avec des supers
chaussures est en fête
en fait en vrai dans la vie à marche
pieds nus un peu comme moi et c'était
dit non mais je veux pas faire trop je
voudrais pas et puis tout le monde lui à
d'humeur mais c'est mon avis les pieds
nus donc est ce dû à la gorge il est
pieds nus marc langlois a arrêté
d'écouter les grandes personnes
c'est facile à dire mais c'est du boulot
à faire j'arrive morales
il aurait pu rester au stade de l'idée
qu'il avait entendu au québec est géré
au second peut-être d'autres l'offrons
non ils apprécient d et puis il est
passé à l'action il a monté des
dispositifs est il allé sur le terrain
pour le faire je me questionne beaucoup
sur cette question de passage à l'action
sur sûre qu'est ce qui empêche qu est ce
qui permet qu est-ce qu il favorise le
passage à l'action et et si j'ai la
question on espère que vous m'excuserez
mais en fait j'ai pas la réponse alors à
ce moment où vous dites vous vouliez
mais qu'est ce qu'il fout là pas avoir
des réponses à rien en fait j'ai pas la
réponse mais je pars la réponse musclée
que celle des histoires des histoires de
personnes qui sont passées à l'action et
je vais vous raconter certaines de ces
histoires
la première histoire que je vous
raconterai vous raconter c'est celle de
firefox
aujourd'hui le web ça nous paraît
évident que qu'il est libre qu'il est
ouvert
ça nous paraît évident que le web
n'appartient pas une seule entreprise
qui n'appartient pas à un seul
gouvernement
ça nous paraît évident que n'importe qui
peut créer son site web et le diffuser
au monde entier sans restriction sauf
dans certains pays
et contrairement par exemple à si on
veut diffuser une radio où là on est
obligé de demander une autorisation
ça nous paraît évident mais en 2003
c'est pas si évident en fait aujourd'hui
les navigateurs web donc c'est mozilla
firefox chrome safari d'apple
internet explorer à l'époque j'en ai que
netscape et internet explorer et en 2003
internet explorer a gagné ce qu'on
appelle à la première guerre des
navigateurs internet explorer à 95 % de
part de marché le web va être un produit
microsoft
mais donc netsky paraître je suis assez
bon l'a perdue et mais il ya une dizaine
d'anciens employés netscape qui disent
non le web le web il faut que ça existe
c'est faux il faut qu'on ait cette plate
forme universelle qui va tourner au quai
sur windows mais aussi sur mac sur linux
pourquoi pas un jour on aura des
téléphones portables sur lesquels on
pourra aller sur internet
ils y croient en ce rêve ici croit et
donc ils se disent on va agir on va
faire quelque chose alors ils auraient
pu aller devant les bureaux de microsoft
et dire on rendez-nous des parts de
marché on veut le web multi par thibault
non il est bon ils font pas ça ils se
disent on va construire et on va
construire une alternative et et ils le
font en fait ils prennent leur valeur et
puis les cris du code qui est un produit
concurrent qu'il ya enfin le dock le
code c'est ce qu'on utilise pour
construire des logiciels et donc ils
font ils font ce qu'ils font ce logiciel
alternatif mais il met aussi leur valeur
dedans et ça va marcher et ça va marcher
et fire fois que va être le succès qu'on
connaît ils vont arriver à croquer 25%
de parts de marché à ce géant qu'est
microsoft que tout le monde pensait
complètement indétrônable bas ils ont
réussi voilà seulement mais ils ont
réussi 25 % de parts de marché
aujourd'hui un demi milliard de
personnes utilisent firefox en ce que ce
que je retiens de cette histoire par
rapport au passage à l'action
c'est que peu importe l'ambition de la
tâche il faut pas se décourager avant
même d'avoir essayé parce que des fois
on peut même réussir la deuxième
histoire que je vais vous raconter ses
selles c'est celle du tee shirt que je
porte d'un de ces t-shirts cc histoire
d'un ami qui bossait dans une boîte il
était styliste et il bosse dans une
boîte il devait faire la collection duo
pour cette boîte bien un moment il dit
quand même
les tissus sont fabriqués à un envoi
transportés en camions sur les milliers
de kilomètres envoyé envoyer les
t-shirts finis sont envoyés en avions
jusqu'en france
dans sa collection bio mais c'est pas
très bien au point alors il se dit non
on peut faire mieux je peux faire mieux
je peux faire des t-shirts qui vont être
joli
moderne a pas des trucs qui gravent
pourri mais qui vont être bio et
équitable au sens commerce équitable
alors il quitte il quitte son poste et
il monte sa boîte bon par contre il
connaît rien aux commerciaux marketing
alors alors il y fait un stage de pôle
emploi pour encourager pour de suivi des
porteurs de projets entrepreneuriaux
et puis à commence commence quelque
chose commence un cycle de six mois où
il va parler de son projet il va faire
que ça il va monter son business plan à
la virgule près et puis il va en parler
et puis les gens adorent son idée et
puis c'est rassurant et puis tous les
jours y rentrer chez lui est heureux
puisque les gens adorent son idée c'est
génial on va changer le monde du textile
on va c'est génial et et pendant six
mois en fait ils sauront rien il se
passe rien et donc un moment il est
quand même lui même fatigués de cette
situation la queue pendant six mois il
se passe pas grand chose et donc ils
décident d'aller faire un tee shirt vous
savez comme dans tous ses boutiques où
on peut faire ses t-shirts donc il prend
un de ses design il l'est il amène il le
fait imprimer et puis il allie la ch'ti
chat puis là dans la main ils le parti
pis de ces proprement le tee shirt il
est moche il pas bio mais il était là il
le portait et à ce moment là il se rend
compte que les mots d'encouragement les
mots de soutien
ils ont en fait aucune valeur que la
révolution qui veut apporter au monde du
textile n'aura pas lieu seulement avec
les mots d'encouragement mais il faudra
que des gens portent ces tee-shirts
peu de temps après il en sera il en sera
la fabrication des 500 premiers tee
shirt
ce que je retiens de cette histoire par
rapport aux au passage à l'action c'est
trois choses la première c'est qu'on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir toutes les
compétences
a priori pour se lancer on peut se
lancer quand même faut pas se bloquer là
dessus la deuxième je les oublier et la
troisième c'est que c'est que pour se
lancer c'est qu'on sait qu'on peut pas
se lancer forcément du premier coup et
que pour se lancer il faut parfois
ricochet le faire en plusieurs fois
si oui donc la troisième la deuxième
c'est que c'est que quand on a une bonne
idée qu'on reçoit du feedback positif il
ya un risque de rester de rester dans le
monde des idées de jamais avancé et faut
y être méfiant la troisième histoire que
je vais vous raconter quand quant au
passage à l'action c'est une des miens
c'est celle et coding goûtez donc
j'écris du logiciel et j'ai un petit peu
réfléchi à comment ça marche et à
comment les utiliser est ce qu'on peut
en faire et à au moins j'étais révoltée
j'étais révoltée par voir certaines
entreprises est et ce qu'elle faisait
avec du logiciel la manière dont est
privée de certaines libertés
thomas on a parlé beaucoup mieux que moi
tout à l'heure ce qui me révolte est le
plus c'était pas tellement leurs
agissements que je trouvais pas éthiques
ce qui me révolte est le plus c'était
que personne vraiment comprenait pas ce
qu'on vit dans une sorte d'illettrisme
technologique généralisée qui comprend
vraiment cette histoire de facebook à
manipuler des sentiments des gens qui
comprend vraiment l'horreur et est ce
que ça signifie pour nos démocraties que
la nsa donc les révélations des noirs
snowden et que la nsa espionne tout le
monde
en mode présence présomption de
culpabilité constamment pas grand monde
et ça me touchait alors on pourrait se
dire que c'est le rôle de l'école pour
les institutions et c'est cool c'est le
rôle de l'école de 2,2 d'éduquer les
citoyens sur ces questions là est ou non
on peut agir tout de suite et donc ce
que j'ai fait peu de temps après avoir
rencontré ceux qui ont initié le
mouvement
à paris j'ai commencé les coding goûter
à bordeaux alors que d'y goûter c'est
quoi c'est le stade 3 2 ce qui
expliquait sa doublette sait on apprend
en s'amusant en fait j'en suis pas
encore au stade iv c'est un moment
convivial où on va où les parents les
enfants vont apprendre ensemble les
bases de la programmation informatique
et l'idée c'est ses fers qui commence à
se poser des questions tiens je viens
d'écrire un programme et puis je peux
lire celui de mon voisin est ce que je
peux lire les programmes des
applications qui tournent sur mon
téléphone
bon je m'égare on revient sur le sur le
passage à l'action le le le relativement
au passage à l'action c'était facile en
fait pour moi d'organiser les coding
goûter parce que j'avais tout ce qu'il
fallait autour de moi j'avais un lieu
dédié au numérique à bordeaux qu'elle
pouvait accéder gratuitement quand je
voulais j'avais pour organiser ces
ateliers j'avais des canaux de
communication pour atteindre les parents
qui seraient très certainement les
cibles pour y inscrire leurs enfants et
j'avais aussi un capital social sert des
gens qui me connaissent des gens qui me
font confiance que je vais pas perdre
leur après midi
s'ils viennent à passer avec moi donc
finalement c'est assez facile
d'organiser les coding goûteurs bon même
si c'était facile
le jour même le jour du tout premier
j'avais un petit un petit stress est le
marquand glace est quoi je parle
ce petit stress on tient on se pose
toutes les questions du monde comment ça
se passait
mais est ce que je suis vraiment
compétents pour faire ça et est ce que
si un môme qui me pose une question que
je sais pas répond est-ce que je vais
pas passer pour un débile
et puis je me suis lancée quand même
parce que de façon résister l'âme
j'avais pas pareil et donc et puis ça
s'est bien passé en fait et c'est rigolo
parce que edward est d'amener qui sont
mes acolytes du codeem goûter chacun à
juste avant leur premier kooning ou
tester dans le même état et puis à la
fin c'est passé et puis maintenant quand
on rencontre des gens qui mais peut-être
que j'aimerais vous aider mais je suis
pas sûr d'avoir le honduras est ce que
ce que je retiens ce que je retiens des
que decoding août et quant au passage à
l'action c'est c'est que il faut savoir
reconnaître quand on a toutes les
ressources à disposition qui permette
que le passage à l'action porte ses
fruits
ce que je retiens aussi pour paraphraser
le sage clôche x sur twitter s'est passé
à l'action
à chaque fois on tergiverse avant de
tremper un doigt mais mais dès qu'on l'a
fait qu'à ce qu'elle est bonne fac à ce
que l'eau est bonne georges
ok alors jetez-vous à l'eau dans poche
ça casse tous les faits
jetez vous à l'eau
voyez à mes amis de montpellier de lyon
de nantes qui à chaque fois que je vois
mais peut-être on aimerait faire l'écho
d'un goûter comme tu as fait et
peut-être que et jetez-vous bordel
faites-le lancé lancé vous si vous êtes
couturiers et couturières de talent que
vous avez un quelconque autre talent
photographe je sais pas ce que vous
pensez que vous pouvez faire mieux que
là où vous êtes que vous avez quelque
chose à apporter
foncez pensez vous et vous dans la salle
qui rit et laruns et vous dans les lieux
relais et vous qui regardez peut-être la
vidéo quelles sont vos idées
quels sont vos idéaux qu'est ce que vous
faites lundi pour passer de l'idée à
l'action
merci